there has been a horrible terror attack
in Strasbourg France and as of just a
few hours ago three people were killed
twelve injured by the shooter who is a
man known to law enforcement in the city
of Strasbourg France this happened near
a Christmas market at one of the city's
central squares the motive is unclear
the shooter was at large as of last
night what we do know about the 29 year
old shooter is that he was born in
Strasbourg right in the same city and
country where the attack took place
that's where the shooter was born he was
reportedly according to French law
enforcement radicalized to an extreme
form of Islam while he was in prison go
figure
so this takes place absolutely
horrifying horrifying terror attack and
what is our president say well Donald
Trump tweets in response to this terror
attack another very bad terror attack in
France we are going to strengthen our
borders even more Chuck and Nancy must
give us the votes to get additional
border security of course referring to
the abortive meeting with Chuck Schumer
and Nancy Pelosi where Trump is trying
to convince them to vote for his
us-mexico border wall so let's analyze
this on its merits and think about
whether it makes any sense a french-born
man shoots people in the city of his
birth born in Strasbourg shoots people
in Strasbourg and Donald Trump uses that
to justify a wall between the United
States and Mexico now you could be for
or against the Mexican wall right I've
pointed out that most undocumented
immigrants are not coming in through
that border physically so I've
questioned the value of that wall
certainly the United States legally can
build it you can debate whether you want
the wall or you don't want the wall but
there is no argument that Donald Trump's
tweet has any bearing on or rather that
the attack in France has any bearing on
the building of the wall and that's what
Donald Trump is tweeting about it's
unrelated there is no connection between
the building the value the virtue
building a Mexican border wall when
there is a shooting in France
perpetrated in the city where a French
man was born now the other
interpretation is well a French man
shooting people in France is evidence of
the need for a us-mexico border wall
because Trump is implying that French
shooters like this guy will go to Mexico
and then come into the United States
through the u.s. Mexico border wall
that's extraordinarily dumb but it
doesn't actually seem to be what Donald
Trump is saying so where I end up on
this Pat is that this is about the
shooter being a brown skinned Muslim I
you know we talked about destructive
identity politics and identity as a
factor that informs what people think
and how people react and what their
beliefs are anyone who pays attention to
this show knows that I don't dance
around
I don't obfuscate that most terror in
the world is committed by men who are
Muslim I have no interest in hiding that
or apologizing for it it's just the
truth in this case though Donald Trump
is taking advantage of this imagery of a
brown skinned Muslim man radicalized in
a French prison to talk about building a
us-mexico border wall what other
connection is there Pat Brown people in
Mexico and a brown guy did the shooting
I can't think of any other way in which
that shooting relates to the us-mexico
border wall and offhand I can't think of
any instance where a terrorists from
Mexico or another part of Latin America
came here through undocumented
immigration and committed an act of
terrorism here in the United States now
I'm sure there are some but there
certainly isn't any example that comes
to mind offhand I think he makes the
argument though that someone from the
Middle East is going to somehow make it
over to Latin America and then come up
and cross the border illegally now why
that they would do that I have no idea
but that's the argument that he's been
trying to make yeah no other explanation
really makes sense that it's in one way
or another
either the way Pat suggested or the way
I'm suggesting related to the fact that
this was a brown-skinned terrorists
because remember after the Florida high
school shooting after
Thousand Oaks shooting after the
Pittsburgh synagogue shooting and many
others which have also had nothing to do
with people coming to the United States
Trump said nothing about the wall
because the perpetrators were white no
wall anywhere would have prevented what
happened in France no wall would have
prevented the incidents that Donald
Trump chooses not to make about the
us-mexico border wall so using it to
justify walls is silly except for the
fact that the guy is brown and of course
this also ignores that in the United
States since every country has its own
problems most of the terrorists in the
United States are domestically born
white men I mean the I know people don't
like to hear that there are people who
consider themselves realists of
different kinds who don't like to hear
that but that's the reality and so we
have an increasingly desperate Donald
Trump the shellacking that he got from
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer in the
Oval Office on on Tuesday really left
him rattled and he's making even less
sense than usual and this is what we get
Strasburg born man shoots people in
Strasburg clearly the United States
needs a us-mexico border wall if there
is another more charitable
interpretation of this that I've not
mentioned get in touch because I have no
interest in unfairly criticizing this I
think we've sort of explored all of the
possibilities about what was going on in
Trump's mind here today's program was
made possible in part by Blink esteem /
Pakman I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show I'm sure you love politics
and learning and what blinka studs is
take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15 minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t-dot-com
slash PA k ma n to sign up